how hard is the
multi-protein folding problem is that
kind of
something you've already mentioned which
is baked into this idea of greater and
greater complexity of proteins
like multi-domain proteins does that
basically become multi-protein
like complexes it's yes you you got it
right so so
it's sort of it has
the components of both of protein
folding
and protein protein interactions
because in order for these domains i
mean many of these
proteins actually they never form a
stable structure
uh you know one of my favorite proteins
you know and uh
pretty much everyone who who works in
the
i know who whom i know who works in the
you know
with proteins they always have their
favorite proteins
right so so one of my favorite proteins
are probably my favorite protein the one
that i worked
when i was a postdoc is so-called
post-synaptic density
95 psd 95 protein so it's uh
it's one of the key actors
in uh in the majority of uh neurological
processes at the molecular level so it's
a
and it essentially it's a it's a key
player
in the postsynaptic density so this is
the crucial part of this
uh synapse where you know a lot of these
chemoliquor processes are happening
so it's it has five domains
right so five protein domains so pretty
you know
large proteins uh i think uh 600
something amino acids uh
but you know the way it's organized
itself
it's flexible right so it acts as a
scaffold
so it is used to bring
in other proteins so they start
acting in the orchestrated manner
right so and the the type of the shape
of this protein
it's in a way there are some stable
parts of this
uh protein but there are some flexible
and this flexibility
is built in into the protein in order to
become sort of this
multifunctional uh machine so do you
think
that kind of thing is also learnable
through the alpha fold to kind of
approach
i mean the time will tell is it another
level of complexity is it is it uh like
how big of a jumping complexity is that
whole thing
to me it's it's yet another level of
complexity because when we talk about
uh protein protein interactions and
there is actually a a
a different challenge for this called
capri and so this
that is focus specif specifically on
macromolecular interactions
protein protein for dna etc so
uh but it's you know
there are different mechanisms
uh that govern molecular interactions
and that need to be picked up
say by a machine learning uh algorithm
uh interestingly enough
we actually we participated uh
for a few years in this competition
we typically don't participate in
competitions
i don't know don't have enough time
you know because it's very intensive
yeah yeah it's a very intensive process
but we participated back in
um you know about 10 years ago
so and the way we entered this
competition so we
design a scoring function right so the
function that evaluates
whether or not your protein protein
interaction is supposed to look like
experimentally solved right so the
scoring function is very critical part
of the of the uh model prediction
so we designed it to be a machine
learning one and so
it was one of the first machine learning
based scoring function
used in capri and uh
you know we essentially you know learned
what
should contribute what are the critical
components contributing
into the protein protein interaction so
this this could be converted into
learning problem and thereby could be
it could be learned i believe so yes
you